they're also now UFC fighter yes I've
been in UFC now for three years three
years yeah sometime how's that going
good handed a I'm on a three fight
winning streak got another one coming up
June 1st mm-hmm
should be fun okay we're gonna get into
we're gonna have some fun okay I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get your reaction to to
you know the whole busting Citadel oh
yeah okay I heard something and I want
takeoff from here and it all connects
we'll connect it all so we're gonna go
we're gonna hear this from you you know
Matt Serra a former UFC champion yeah he
has that show and he has he had one of
his guests I forgot what his name is
let's listen to this clip and then okay
let me now go into my question how's it
yep sound good you just came up with
that that word terrorist he's lucky to
get charged with the terrorist act
because he came from another country
came here with 20 guys to start trouble
and attack Abebe so he's lucky to get
charged with that okay so I want you to
imagine this Mohammed Bulow he's coming
over from Palestine right he's got 30
brothers with him he's on Oh see your
American citizen right I wouldn't do
something like that obviously but just
paint the picture now right because we
call out a lot of the double standards
out there you know some of the open you
know hypocrisy that's around there so
I'm just I'm just envisioning okay in
your head you got Mohammed Bella he's on
a work work work visa right because kind
of McGregor he's coming from another
country he's on a work visa right yeah I
didn't mention it but this just had my
school my my I was thinking what I heard
I don't know who the co-host is from the
who was that speaking the the guy whose
mess Aryan uh what's his name I know you
don't talk about he's an actor famous
actor right yeah okay so he said it he
said man he's lucky hitting a charged
with terrorism what do you think would
happen to you
or any Muslim vite vite anyway yeah
they're definitely getting arrested
we're going to jail for a while I know I
think we're getting kicked out of the
UFC is going to be in the papers as a
terrorist and it's gonna the headlines
gonna read Muhammad that's gonna be like
the first one Muhammad terrorist attacks
bus guaranteed hundred percent so I mean
like you said it's a double standard
he's kind of regret and uh right now
he's like the face of the organ
so like the UFC's it not gonna punish
him like they would it like any other
UFC fighter they would have been cut
right away hundred percent but it's kind
of a Greg I know he brings in the money
but doing something like that like you
have little kids looking up some kids
watching them and then they see him
doing something like that so they're
gonna think the same thing that they
could do something like that if they
wanted to or they could go to school and
hurt somebody or throw stuff at windows
break windows that nothing I happened to
them just because they're looking at
their idol kind of McGregor and
nothing's happening to them and he's
laughing about it and he's just having
fun with it so I mean now that UFC could
play it off as a promotional thing now
cuz you know they're gonna play it him
and could be been the fighting they're
gonna play that but stent the whole time
as promoting it so I mean in the long
run it's gonna make them money but on it
I'm like a personal thing I think makes
them look bad mm-hmm even if you don't
want their responsibility by being in
the spotlight you obviously have people
I like what you said you know young kids
you know kids are gonna be looking at
you and they're gonna end up you know
throwing a tantrum throwing you know
whatever comes whatever it's accessible
hurt maybe here he could have killed
somebody you know I mean yeah exactly a
dolly goes to the window and it could've
hit him in the head or I mean it caught
one of them but and the other guy had a
glass go in his eye so that could have
seemed blind to them or really put them
out like I don't think like his first
thing when I thought thought about that
first thought it was like a stunt and
the UFC was like just playing it off but
then when I saw guys get hurt off it I
feel like it just went too far I feel
like he probably had the idea where I'm
gonna go out there and just make make a
little noise get a little attention off
of it but then he just puppy you just
went nuts on there just started throwing
stuff throwing the wrong things
I get that our trash can hit the thing
you know it's not gonna the windows not
gonna break anything like that
and make you look it will promote it a
little bit but you're throwing dollies
and uh metal spears or something through
the window so I'm like no people get
hurt
was there any formal apology to this day
that you know of no nothing from kind of
a Gregor the the UFC said it and Dana
White said he's talked to Conor McGregor
and like they had their heart-to-heart
whatever and he's apologized today in a
way during like that but I haven't seen
anything publicly from Conor yet that's
another thing I mean obviously as human
beings we make mistakes you know and to
be unapologetic and something that you
should be apologizing for that's another
thing that
lessons are learned from people who
might do something like that you're
taking this person or anyone else as an
example
and they're setting bad trends and bad
examples and now they do these bad
things you do it and they're not even
apologetic so you're not apologetic and
you're just like hey what's that famous
statement he has I have I'm sorry for
absolutely yeah how's that for
absolutely nothing
yeah he said I want to apologize to
everybody for absolutely nothing they're
always like trash-talking he's like no
he's fine Eddie Alvarez he was talking
about his family talking about
everything like that and then I have to
really said I'm sorry for absolutely
nothing so now that's like a big mean
that people always post yeah and then
now you got also guys at UFC now that
are trying to like take after him
because they see him getting all the
money so what are they doing they're
gonna start talking trash to people
being unsportsmanlike and then just
trying and like you could tell you're
Conor kind of good at it like you could
tell he's good Eddie's practice it but
some guys now are just trying too hard
to be that that villain and not to beat
Kobe Kobe Cummington if you look at him
talking about Brazil talking about
Brazil saying it's a dump
saying the people from there are trash
when he fights a Brazilian guy and then
like you could tell it's fake it's under
percent fake it's just him trying to
play a role as a villain but you're
putting all those people like the
Brazilian fans everybody into like
making them all feel bad making them all
hate you it's gonna make it's gonna make
other kids think all right I could say
the same thing or I'm a basketball
player I'm I'm a like 10 year old kid
and I see him talking trash about a
whole country why can't I do the same
thing about this other team or this
school like your whole schools trash
anybody from that area's trash so it's
gonna make everything look bad and then
yeah and and it goes back do you have
been a bigger responsibility and now you
have the spotlight and now people are
you know we're creatures of imitation
and I'm people are imitating you and the
bad things I like what this cyborg
you know cyborg yeah I've seen her
actually wearing hijab I don't know if
you ever seen her yeah saying
masha'Allah you know got a little bit
and and and doing some really she she
actually you know how hobby and and this
is what I kind of went away from from
watching many of the the UFC's and
whatnot but what drew me one time is I
was I was with my cousins and family
where they kept telling me about this
this Muslim UFC guy and then I watched
his fight one time and what really you
know
touched me was when he stopped
afterwards and he thanked the Almighty
he thanked the Creator I wanna sell
hamdullah without God we cannot do
nothing everything is nothing you know
number one we live on your one God
Joseph I want to say thank you for God
God is number one other things is
nothing you know it's me me you know
yeah and he made such that he went and
he prostrated you know what I mean I was
really impressed with that you know what
I mean and and then we see I don't know
if they did this before and again it
goes back to like people setting good
trends she went out she was feeding the
poor yeah she's not Muslim she's
Christian but that's a good thing we
could we commend that that's what we
need more of you know yeah what do you
what do you that was she was like after
her last fight she went out and I think
she she was that like UFC 200 or
something she went on to give out like
200 meals to kids and the poor people
out there and that's something that the
UFC should be promoting that's the
things that man that's a beautiful thing
that she's going out there she's
promoting that and like you said it
could be every single fight giving us
thanks to giving us time to left for
everything and then even after is title
fight it's not me it's it's from God
that's what that's what it right after
his title fight that's what he's gonna
Mike and I think that's gonna be huge
that we got our first Muslim champion
because it's gonna show it's gonna put
us in the limelight more and it can show
like how Muslims are humble and like
from when you right now when you look at
the news or anything like that they're
always showing shining the light on all
the negative things that happen to
Muslims or guys that say they're Muslims
and they're terrorists and they're all
of this and all that so now shine the
light on a great Muslim a great humble
Muslim that's a champion that's a real
champion and he's still humble and still
not changing like kind of McGregor Conor
McGregor got his money now and he's
becoming that that villain now he
doesn't care what people think of him or
its had that attitude like I'm gonna do
me no matter what I don't care if I have
kids looking up to me I don't care if I
I just had a kid I don't care about any
of that now I'm I'm still the money
maker and I'm still gonna be the
businessman I want to be mm-hmm
could be more of a Muslim before he's a
Muslim before a businessman yeah that's
and many people don't know it's you know
and this is the unique thing about our
show usually because people when they
can't identify with something it's kind
of like the other but once we like
Muslim is simply one who
children to submit to the crater that's
it some people submit to money some
people submit to themselves you know and
their desire is but a Muslim is one who
simply submits to the creator of all
things and that's oh we're humbly trying
to do and tell me do you get some
bullying yourself now I mean some people
might not know I'm most Eddy you know
what I mean and and it's not in the name
you know what I mean it's like you got
Muslim can mean it can be named Mohammed
can be named Mike you know it's it's
someone a Muslim can be from Italy from
from Japan from all over you know to me
so that's one misconception many people
have do you think Muslims are Arabs
you know they mean but Muslims are you
know from all walks of life
do you now because you have the name
Muhammad right but al yeah do you get
some people trying to bully you like
social media social media uh it's not
yeah obviously not person you know the
the keyboard tough guy yeah you know
yeah you always key board tough guys
that are always right right when I post
like a poster or something like that of
my next coming to fight and I'd be like
who's a terrorist how does that tell you
see letting a terrorist in a cyber
bullying yeah ufc's letting a terrorist
in the UFC I'm like what the heck but
it's funny and then you have like guys
that are randomly like make weird posts
cuz up my sister she's uh she works with
a fun fundraiser in Chicago it's called
pcrf like Palestinian Children's Relief
Fund in Palestine and then like I'll
post something about that and then some
guy made like a whole article about how
that that fund is like promoting and
helping terrorists and uh Palestine and
Gaza and I'm like we're like where do
people use to come up with these stories
but they just waste their time to come
up with a whole story shining a negative
light on Muslim just trying to do good